[SPEAKER_00]: Seventh of Whalesun, Merrick, probably around noon.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, basically if you do this, you're checking the entire channel between Redshore and Keoland, Salamor, and the surrounding seas.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you'll know everything in the channel.
[SPEAKER_00]: Names & No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you go on the deck of the boat and scan out and look around.
[SPEAKER_00]: And what this tells you is in a six-mile radius, if there are any turtle dragons, any dragons also tell you in dead, crazy stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: They are sahuagin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not a lot.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't get to know exactly the number.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are no turtle dragons, however.
[SPEAKER_00]: No dragons at all on the seas.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that's just the channel.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can kind of tell that there are no dragons probably two miles to the south of the Red Shore Island either.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so at least in the area right around Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, if you walk to the east side and the west side and check, that would be bigger territory.
[SPEAKER_00]: But the thing is that you know it instantaneously.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not something that you can know forever.
[SPEAKER_00]: But right now, no, they're not.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're all out of here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there anything else you want to ask me?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't say anything to Helm about dragons or anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I don't know if Tyrus, because he's been saying things, I don't know if he's been saying it to Helm.
[SPEAKER_01]: I need to put Tyrus in check for a second.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.